tenemos la expresión menos 30 x a la 5
igual a menos 10 x al cubo que
multiplica a efe así que te invito a que
hagas una pausa para tratar de
determinar quién tiene que ser
efe ok y la forma de abordar el problema
es tratando de aislar a efe y eso lo
podemos hacer simplemente si dividimos
de ambos lados entre menos 10 x al cubo
muy bien entonces si dividimos de este
lado entre menos 10 x al cubo para
lograr que se mantenga la igualdad
también tenemos que dividir del lado
izquierdo entre menos 10 x al cubo
verdad que es lo que va a ocurrir bueno
del lado derecho tendremos menos 10 x al
cubo que multiplica efe
y luego dividimos entre menos 10 x al
cubo esto en realidad sería como
multiplicar por menos 10 x al cubo y
dividir entre menos 10 x al cubo esto
simplemente es como multiplicar por 1
cierto es decir esto se cancela verdad
entonces
derecho nosotros simplemente tendremos
efe que es justamente lo que queremos
encontrar mientras que del lado
izquierdo tenemos que hacer varias
operaciones lo que podemos hacer primero
es dividir menos 30 que entre menos 10 y
eso nos va a quedar un resultado
positivo verdad entonces simplemente
sería 30 entre 10 nos da 3 y luego
tenemos que dividir x a la 5 entre x al
cubo verdad entonces una forma de
hacerlo puede salir por ejemplo si
utilizamos las propiedades de los
exponentes verdad simplemente a 5 le
restamos 3 y nos da x cuadrada muy bien
otra forma de determinar cómo es que nos
da x cuadrada podría ser la siguiente
por ejemplo tenemos x por x por x por x
por x
esto simplemente es x al a5 verdad
estamos multiplicando cinco veces a x y
luego dividimos entre
x al cubo verdad que sería x x x x x
sería multiplicar tres veces a x consigo
misma y entonces podemos ver que estas
tres x se cancelan y sólo nos quedan 2 x
multiplicándose que simplemente sería x
cuadrada muy bien entonces esencialmente
tenemos quienes f
efe sería 3x cuadrada así que podemos es
expresar lo anterior como menos 30 x
elevado a las 5 esto tendría que ser
igual a menos 10 x al cubo que
multiplica a efe verdad pero efe ya
sabemos que es 3 x al cuadrado muy bien
entonces otra forma de decir exactamente
lo mismo que tenemos aquí es que la
expresión menos 30 x a la 5 es divisible
entre menos 10 x al cubo o bien también
es equivalente a decir que menos 30 x a
la 5 es divisible entre 3 x cuadrada
otra forma podría ser decir que
unos 10 x al cubo es factor de menos 30
x a la 5 o bien que 3x cuadrada es
factor de menos 30 x a las 5 la idea
aquí es que podemos hablar de
divisibilidad ya que tenemos
coeficientes que no son fraccionarios
verdad y también tenemos exponentes que
no son fraccionarios es decir tanto la
expresión magenta o amarilla verdad son
factores de la expresión azul o bien
podemos decir que la expresión azul es
divisible entre cualquiera de estos 2